there's a large amount of working from
home goes on and all levels of
employment from the call center people
that we were dealing with were
reasonably lowly paid and not terribly
skilled up through programmers regularly
worked from home database administrators
regularly worked from home several of
the most prominent Valley firms
encourage managers to work from home and
this is the first evidence we have about
the efficacy of that what we found was
that working from home turned out to be
a win-win the employees the employees
were happier because they weren't having
to commute an hour and a half a day the
firms saved on real estate and the
employees worked more and worked more
efficiently more because saving time on
commuting they didn't have to take time
off to go to the dentist or take the
kids to the doctor and more effectively
because working at home was quieter than
working in the noisy call centers so
they didn't have to ask clients to
repeat themselves the people who were
working at home worked about 9% longer
and was 9 percent bigger share of their
assigned 8-hour shift
they took smaller breaks and fewer hour
time off and they also were about four
percent more effective so 13 percent
gain you know but then once people were
allowed to decide where they wanted to
work it jumped to 22 percent and a large
part of this was that some people found
though they thought they wanted to work
at home they were just too lonely they
wanted to get back to the office and so
the people who chose to work from home
knowing what they were getting into were
even more
and more productive working from home
works really well for some people that's
we've we've proven that and some people
in some companies some jobs I don't
think it necessarily would work well for
all people in all jobs at all times
there's the the manager has to
understand the tasks that are involved
in the job understand the mechanisms it
can be used to control and motivate the
employees who are working at home and
has to understand the the social
implications a lot of our employees at
sea trip became lonely and didn't want
to work at home anymore you'd worry that
in another context people who were not
in frequent contact with one another
would be less innovative you really just
have to think through the individual
situation and maybe run your own
experiment what the CEO Marissa Mayer at
Yahoo is doing isn't really much about
working from home or not working from
home it's about not working yahoo has
been a company in big trouble in a death
spiral for several years and as I
learned while being interviewed
repeatedly about her outlined working
from home the company just wasn't
working and people weren't working
people who were nominally working from
home or in fact setting up their own
companies on Yahoo's time and the
culture at Yahoo had become really
dysfunctional and what I see her doing
is trying to change the culture to save
the company and and that's this is one
element of it she's cutting you got to
do that face to face you can't do that
over over email
if workers want to want to experiment
with working from home one of the things
to do is to approach the boss with with
some data and the old data is a start
but this new data is is gold standard
stuff how much you want to rely on our
work rather than other stuff may depend
a lot on how much your job looks like
the call centers where the bosses can be
sure that you'll be motivated to work
once you're home and not to sit around
in your bathrobe and play Angry Birds
this is an area where there's been
really no scientific research at all
there's surveys and there's case studies
but you never have any idea what's
really cause and effect in a situation
like that whereas here because of the
randomization we could pretty well
ensure that that the changes we saw were
driven by the changes in the management
practice and anytime you find management
good evidence that management really
works for somebody who's spent 40-plus
years teaching management that's that's
a good day